did you guys hear about this um
uh the race that congress gave
themselves did you see the race it's
very honorable so if you want to go to
this page five
uh congress decides to give them a raise
uh
i think it's on page six okay congress
gives themselves a double digit race
this is a town hall
story amid economic turmoil for the
american people they're represented in
washington gave their office
double-digit race this month even as the
average american worker finds their real
wages decreasing due to inflation that
outpaces wages at new if you miss
congress given itself a little pat on
the back
that's understandable members aren't
likely to tout outside the beltway how
they're filing their own uh filling
their own
office coffers plus the funding increase
for congressional offices just went uh
was just one part of the 2700 page
omnibus bill that funded the us
government into a one and a half
trillion dollars the roll call explains
5.9 billion fiscal 2022 legislative
branch
funding the increased taxpayer funding
for congressional offices is 134 million
dollars more than was allocated in the
last fiscal year a 21
increase according to the house
appropriations committee summary in
addition congressional offices in the
house side get 18.2 million dollars in
paid internships that 21 21 raise for
the offices with a 5.1 percent
year-over-year wage growth for household
reporting on february's job report and
you can see why americans might not be
that thrilled and frustrated that's why
i asked tyler to ask to check how much
the military got a raise in the last uh
12 months 2.7 percent raise so they get
a 2.7 percent raise and they give
themselves a 21 raise gotta love it i
mean this is a very honorable move for
them
you gotta think you know with all the
bipartisanship that's going on in
congress finally there's something they
agree upon let's give ourselves more
money anyone object mcconnell pelosi all
right let let's do it all right
more money term limits term limits term
limits that's this i mean it is
astounding when you look at the size of
of of of the operation of congress
and the number of staffers they've got
um
god yeah i can't say enough bad things
they're so dysfunctional that's the
other part of it is and we we're clearly
not sending our best and brightest to
washington i mean i think
possibly most people would hopefully
agree on that
but the system is designed to it seems
like increasingly send
dysfunctional people to washington well
as i say every now and then an innocent
man is sent to the legislature
by the way i want to just get a quick
look at congressional approval ratings
and where they stand right now tyler's
on the scene
where do they stand tyler i think it
just said eighteen percent all right
well they're still in double digits guys
they're still in double digits
by the way
i'm curious i'm curious like what other
things should we look at for uh raises
that are given so military being one of
them uh old old folks retirements
they're getting what social security
check to see how much social security
raises they did increase it okay if it
matches it i respect it if you if you
increase social security
so if your social security is what uh uh
are there net associations getting
better about bonuses
5.9
5.9 while inflation is what seven point
nine percent and you're raising a 5.9
percent but congress got 21 percent it's
not uh
not a again but these are the types of
things that the average person watches
and says let me get this straight
we're going through [ __ ] yeah you're
raising gas prices
i'm going through what i'm going through
right now during this time you secretly
all give yourself a 21 raise but you
don't do it to me so if this were to
happen and they raise social security by
21
they raise military by 21
they raise themselves by 21 then
somebody could say what okay cool i can
see that fine even though the number may
be astronomically high
uh but when you do it and you give
yourself 21 social security 5.9 military
2.7 right it's it's what mike baker
would call it an [ __ ] move
yeah
by the way
take a look the medicare surcharge is
coming so
the six percent they gave you they then
take away on drugs hospitalization and
physicians so it's probably net less for
grandma not to mention the inflation
rate of eight percent
um you know eating into that as well on
grandma's groceries and if you want to
read more about this you can check out
the 2700 page uh bill that's uh reaching
congress right now which nobody read
zero they passed it again
how how
screwed up do you have to be to put
together a 2 700 page omnibus bill
not allow for people to debate it read
it
create some transparency around it for
the voters
and then make a decision and this is but
they do this [ __ ] all the time and i
guarantee the people that wrote those
most of that legislation
they're like 23 year old interns and
staffers you know who you know are
probably over uh i'm not i'm not saying
that's a bad thing atm sounds like we're
gonna get at the atm
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you